What do you want from me
what is this about
Welcome back everyone
is going to be my Loki episode 2 video there
were so many marvel Easter eggs it is ladies night
on Loki if you're new to my channel I'm doing
videos for all the episodes, be sure to subscribe
to get all them.
We're doing a giveaway for Disney plus memberships
all you have to do to enter is be subscriber
and just leave your favorite Easter egg from
the episode on the video careful for spoilers
for everything that happened on Loki so far
if you haven't seen the episodes.
We'll start at the beginning of the episode
and work our way through shot by shot.
And talk about Easter eggs and moments and
foreshadowing.
And I'll number these as we go along to stay
organized starting with the title of the episode.
The variant which is obviously a reference
to both of these lokis the Loki 1130 our main
version of looking out in the other new main
variant Loki the antagonist lady Loki that
they're chasing after this time there's no
cold open, they just do the previously on
and he goes straight to that new Green Loki
themed Marvel Studios logo and they start
at the Renaissance fair in OshKosh Wisconsin
in 1985 there were a couple of really notable
things that happened at marvel during 1985
it was the year the character apocalypse debuted
nebula.
Legion and the flag smasher character which
we just saw on falcon and winter soldier or
a version of flag smasher they also use this
intro scene to introduce one of the new main
TVA hunters see 20, played by Sasha Lane.
She shows up in the trailer footage from later
episodes.
So is is a she could continue to be a big
character in the series.
She's like another version of be 15 just like
another one of these bigger hunters they take
the bait head into the tent and female Loki
gets the drop on them.
The automatic PA system starts up as if it
normally would like a new group of cosplayers
stepped in to participate in this big battle
event and supposed to take place in the tent
to play with a lot of metaphors here.
Like this is a battle of good versus evil
and the prize is the princess which is a reference
to lady Loki, because regular male Loki is
a prince of Asgard, so female version of Loki
would be a princess of Asgard just like Hella
then lady Loki Cason enchantment on Hunter
C 20 so that she starts taking out all the
other TVA Minutemen they use the PA voice
distant descendent that holding out for a
hero song is using is a joke reference to
what Lady Loki has just done turning Hunter
C20 into the hero like the way the think that
she's the antagonist when really like later.
By the end of the episode.
The way they're portraying the time keepers
and all the sinister things are going on of
the TVA as if they are the real villains she
escapes taking Hunter C20 with her and their
wrist technology allowing her to open her
own portals obviously season needs that activate
all the time device bombs use later in the
episode.
But then we jump back to the TVA with our
new Loki at Mobeus his desk reading his JetSki
magazine the funny thing here is the model
looks suspiciously like a much younger version
of Chris Hemsworth just would really short
hair Mobeus does explain the JetSki metaphor
later in the episode two.
Like why he's obsessed with jet skis they
have is big joke with miss minutes on Loki's
desk is is hologram this quizzing him on the
rules of the TVA trying to teach them out
everything is supposed to work.
He kinda pays attention like he answers all
the questions correctly.
But then tries to swat her away like are you
real are you actually listening to me and
she doesn't answer of the kind of both so
she is kind of like a living version of Jarvis
like a really hyper tech version of Jarvis
it seems like her systems are so advanced
and complex I feel like is also a big twist
coming with her character too with miss minutes.
In addition to the big twist with the time
keepers that were all expecting the also use
a lot of these introduction scenes early in
the episode, especially when they go out on
the mission with his version of Loki to reexplain
a lot of the complicated ideas from the episode.
Like had a branch timelines work had a nexus
events work way they explained it once you
go past redline.
The new branch timeline that's created starts
to function like a completely alternate reality
in the TVA can no longer use the time reset
devices to undo any of the harmful changes
miss minutes keeps hyping up how that would
lead to the destruction of the sacred timeline
and the collapse of all reality as they know
it.
Which foreshadows the big twists of the end
of the episode with all the time bombs the
go off at all the different places in time
with the way they hyped this up.
The big sinister overtones the you get from
the time keepers it doesn't sound like that's
the complete truth like a just more the dogma
that the time keepers are forcing on the TVA
workers.
Like they want you to think like it's going
to be the end of all reality like a lot of
people are now wondering if lady Loki created
the multiverse at the end of the episode I
think is said to be a little more complicated
than that, but will get to that in the second
don't worry the just so much stuff that happened
during this episode with a talk about.
But you know Sentry does try to swat miss
minutes hologram she tries to avoid him, then
jumps back into the monitor.
Even though he passed her test she fails them
in she's like frowning at him his is walking
away with Mobeus gets an official TVA jacket
identifying him as a very the kind of used
to make fun of him a little bit and then is
there explain the case they show you a bunch
of alternate versions of Loki.
So like, there's one here with a slightly
different version of his original costumes
the first Thor movie.
Just made to look a little more all tiny but
he's blue because that is his natural skin
color he is a frost giant the only reason
why his skin looks like this is because he
uses his magic to make himself look like other
asgardians they do give you special number
designations for all these different lokis
not all them I think are meant to be specific
comic book references.
But that is another Loki that looks like he
cheated to win the Tour de France go team
Loki, because of his bike shorts here.
Like uses natural extra strength and endurance
that he has as up frost giant to beat everyone
is a version of Loki that seems like he's
half Minotaur like a tauren version of Loki,
it seems like some of these of the Loki's
are also based on classical depictions of
Norse mythological Loki is kind of a satyr
looking version of Loki that a more classic
Norse looking version of Loki, when he says
that sometimes some of these variance powers
are different, but they share some common
powers that is a reference to all the classical
real world depictions of the mythological
Loki, then they have the argument about the
difference between creating duplicates illusions
just as a way for Loki to nerd outlet he goes
full Prof. Loki.
Like how dare you it's much more difficult
to create duplicates this her to set the jokes
about lady Loki being the superior version
of Loki.
Just to make him feel smaller this is all
obviously setting up a big twist for his arc
during the series Mobeus makes a joke about
this later two when he says the real reason
why picked use because I knew you would pursue
this and try to solve the case in order to
prove yourself superior because your ego is
so big the also set this whole idea of Loki
versus the time keepers like Mobeus jokes.
They're not worried about him betraying them
getting his magic powers back, because how
would they get you closer to getting yourself
in front of the time keepers it even though
later in the episode Loki sort of comes clean
about his true plan.
Like he hopes to eventually take out the time
keepers and replace them I think that's also
a misdirect in the will be a big twists when
they do the big Wizard of Oz revealed who's
really behind the curtain was really going
on with the time keepers it is not what anyone
is expecting is that will Loki is expecting
in it's not what fans are expecting either
they portal in in in the do another big exposition
dump explaining how time travel works.
Like how come we don't just travel to before
this whole attack happened.
They had to arrive in the moment with a nexus
event is being created otherwise don't miss
it Iron Man had a conversation about this
during avengers endgame, when he tried to
explain how complex and how hard it was to
time travel correctly the way the producers
talk about the rules of time travel on the
Loki series is that she had to evolve they
to change the rules that they created during
avengers endgame.
Because the rules they set up in avengers
endgame had too many plot holes in it of it
seems like the rules are different now on
the Loki series.
Those are actually the real new rules the
canonical rules of time travel in the MCU
Loki also makes more jokes about TVA propaganda
to like I watched some your videos is propaganda
videos is a term you typically use when you
speak of something sinister, like propaganda
is bad.
This is all just foreshadowing the big TVA
big time keepers reveal.
I don't this can happen for a couple episode.
So don't be surprised if you see more Easter
eggs like this in the background just foreshadowing
for time keepers being the bad characters
here, he also makes a joke about the time
reset devices kind disintegrating everything.
A lot of what happens here in the tent with
them investigating this crime scene is a big
misdirect though with Loki just trying to
speechifying his way into a faster audience
with the time keepers Mobeus calls him out
on it and then they take off after resetting
this area is big speech about wolf's ears
and wolf's teeth that is from actual Norse
mythology though where there are wolf's ears,
wolf's teeth are near, then just as they get
done talking about the time keepers themselves.
They transition to the face of the time keepers
statue is the middle time keeper them of the
kind of looks like the Jonathan majors looking
Kang the conqueror character.
But it is a much better depiction of it in
3D like you actually the reptilian looking
features like Loki calls them space lizards,
because they are reptilian in the comics.
A lot of people were just thinking after episode
one in that whole big secret wars teaser about
the backstory of the TVA that they kind of
change this middle time keeper a little bit
in the MCU explainer for the time keepers
might be a little bit different as well to
help foreshadow a version of Kang the conqueror
in the MCU.
Like MCU Kang will be a little bit different
from comic book Kang, there were literally
a couple Kang Easter eggs that happen right
after this moment to in this scene, but Mobeus
talks about the other artifacts that ravonna
Renslayer in her office here, has collected
from a lot of there big missions you see them
from all different eras in history.
But you also notice that her old helmet in
her old baton are sitting thereto they haven't
really got into her backstory yet, but they'll
get into that in future episodes.
She used to be a hunter in they just worked
her way up and got promoted to a judge.
But she takes him to task on Loki's insubordination,
but then claims Mobeus himself is kind of
insubordinate all the time in then he throws
it right back in her facing that she used
to be just like that too, which I think is
just foreshadowing her eventually helping
them uncover larger shady stuff going on inside
the TVA with the time keepers.
Like eventually she will be an ally to them.
Even though during the episode.
The other TVA hunters seem like they hate
Loki and want to blame him for all the stuff
that goes wrong during their missions.
He also pronounces her name a little bit different
than I expected to he says it revote so you
could say it Ramona ravonna either way you
want this also funny Wandavision callback
to when she calls about for not using a coaster
in the coaster is a hexagon shaped so everybody
poster hexagon jokes.
Jimmy was going crazy about this one Mobeus
also questions the nature the time keepers
like halos timekeepers how they doing in Ramona
doesn't really say much about as you can a
blows past it.
Like she gets all of her orders from them
from her monitor is if she's never actually
talk to them herself either they get into
this later the episode with Mobeus his character
to like Loki is questioning everything.
Like this is all ridiculous who has free will
what is free will mobieus says that he doesn't
question anything in it seems like Ramona
is the same to like up to this point.
She hasn't questioned any of the dogma or
the propaganda the TVA is given her.
But the big Kang the conqueror Easter egg
you probably spotted is when mobieus picks
up her pen it says Franklin D Roosevelt high
school and says it must be from the analyst
that she's keeping on the side.
The pen is blue like the color the fantastic
four.
You could point to the Franklin name is a
is a reference to franklin Richards in just
more association with fantastic four characters
because Kang the conqueror's real name is
Nathaniel Richards he's a distant descendent
of reed Richards from the far future and in
the comics, he was ravonna's long time love
interest switches scenes of the trying to
set that up in the background the MCU.
At this point in Jonathan Majors was actually
asked about this and interview people asked
him if he was going to show up during the
Loki series.
And he just deflected like what I don't know
what you're talking about what itself is her
trying to say that Kang started out as another
analyst just like Mobeus you may have noticed
a familiar Easter eggs as they're working
their way down the elevator like IBC.
This architecture here looks really cool the
way they do this scene it looks really beautiful
and you have the time keepers statues everywhere
in the episode including here.
Like they show up everywhere in the episode.
This whole structure might look familiar because
this is actual hotel in Atlanta that they
go film that shows up in a ton a different
movie.
Just because it looks so unique and so cool
it pricings familiar to because it was also
in this vulture scene from Spider-Man homecoming
is a step in the library here you see that
T-3 72.
That's a reference to Thor issue number 372.
The very first issue where the time variance
authority debuted in the comics, the files
that he starts out reading here are similar
events from the previous Thor movies like
the first Thor movie, then as part of his
grand plan to uncover the darker mysteries
of the TVA the time keepers he asked for files
on the creation of the TVA sort of setting
of that big twist.
Then he asked for files on the beginning of
time the end of time.
All classified.
I of his a big Wizard of Oz reveal.
Like, there's gonna be some big revelation
by the end of the series.
She says the only files that he's allowed
to read are the files on himself the previous
six one six version of Loki that he sort of
spun off of and the variant Loki they're chasing
lady Loki also notice in the background to
in these different levels they have the different
designations here.
Like you have allocate three then to W1 underneath
it though just correspond to the elevator
buttons as the different levels of the time
keepers citadel.
So the next file that he reads is basically
the events of Thor Ragnarok the destruction
of Asgard you see they designated as a class
VII apocalypse later in the episode when they
talk about the hurricane at the roxxcart that
the class X apocalypse it sounds like the
lower the number the bigger the apocalypse
like class I apocalypse would be the worst
kind.
But you notice a bunch of Easter eggs on the
page here.
Like it's is zero variance energy which means
that was supposed to happen.
It's part of the sacred timeline is the time
keepers designated me.
That was destined to happen.
Which is also something from real world Norse
mythology.
Like Ragnarok is always supposed to happen
is all about the cycle of death and rebirth
in mythology Thor and surtur kind of talk
about this during their early conversation
at the beginning of Thor Ragnarok as well.
This big prophecy of Ragnarok lower on the
page here, there's a reference to Thor's revengers
then he sort of get the idea about lady Loki
hiding inside apocalyptic events.
And as he rushes off the elevator to tell
morbius you see more sinister propaganda posters
on the wall here any completely trashes his
salad trying to make a Thor Ragnarok metaphor.
Like if I push the hulk off the rainbow bridge
here.
Just like shaking all the salt and the pepper
in then grabbing the juice box from Casey
for Casey there is a new Easter egg hereto
is that Boku juice box which is another defunct
brand just like the Josta soda like a brand
that's gone out of circulation is reminding
you that the TVA superpowerful they had time
traveled they can get you anything that doesn't
exist anymore because they can go to any place
in the timeline have the joke about Loki stabbing
everyone in the back 50 times.
I when do it again because it's such a boring
form of betrayal.
So he gets in to take him to Pompeii to test
their theory is the volcano is exploding he
says they can do anything they want as long
as it's within certain limits because there's
this bigger apocalypse is going to happen
the timelines get to be wiped anyway.
So Loki does everything he can to violate
the prime directive, so to speak like reveal
all their secrets were from the future.
I know the volcano is going to explode your
old in a died.
Nothing matters Loki's theory is proven correct
in later in the episode.
They even suggest that Lady Loki has kept
coming back to this roxxcart like this is
the place and time that she's always coming
back to because it seems like it's taken her
a while to accumulate all these time reset
devices she's set up in this warehouse the
of a bit of a bonding moment in then Mobeus
explains why he loves JetSki so much when
he says that all things eventually get ruined
I think is more foreshadowing for the time
keepers and the TVA being the real villains
in all this.
Like things start out with a noble goal, that
slowly got perverted and ruined over time
look a very dark knight type of statement.
You either die a hero or live long enough
to see yourself become the villain in the
time keepers are supposed to be a mortal so
they live forever also I hope this is foreshadowing
for them paying off this big JetSki twist
and we actually Mobeus writing a JetSki by
the end of the series.
The other big argument about the nature of
the time keepers and free will.
So IBC more foreshadowing time keepers being
really really bad Loki also has this really
nice quote sort of framing everything in context
saying no one bad is every truly bad in no
one good is every truly good just more foreshadowing
for lady Loki.
Not really being the villain more the time
keepers being villains they use the kablooie
gum to track down lady Loki.
They also use that the set of that funny joke
about there not being candy on Asgard apparently
like he just laughs that I'm like nuts grapes,
no wonder you're so bitter you don't have
candy as a joke about there being apocalypses
all the time on earth.
Like there's so many of their hundreds up
apocalypses every single year revengers commentary
on real life.
Like last year 2020 felt like a very apocalyptic
year they happen all the time.
So roxxcart obviously a reference to rocks
on which is an evil corporation anything about
this to his when they portal in the exit transition
to the sign their of the hurricanes were blowing
it away it actually looks kind of like a sinister
picture like this whole town is meant to be
a corporate town but you look at any of this
really evil corporation sort of sitting casting
the shadow on what seems like a very happy
town like the town has a very happy sounding
name, hiding the sinister nature of the Corporation
which I think is another metaphor for the
TVA itself.
Like very normal sounding name, hiding very
villainous intent not really familiar with
roxxon there a natural resources company.
They showed up during the Asian Carter series
back in the 1940s they're all over marvel
comics in their CEO is actually daario agger
who is the Minotaur a big Thor character that
shows up in the mighty Thor arc right after
Jane foster becomes Thor, which they're doing
during Thor love and thunder.
Pretty soon Mobeus also makes a reference
to Loki being very clever and eventually taking
his job.
I think that's a reference to future seasons
of the show we know there's going to be a
Loki season 2.
And they'll continue on.
But eventually I think the idea is that this
Loki will redeem himself and be recognized
as a full agent of the TVA like Mobeus and
the others.
Even if the TVA itself kind of changes a little
in the big reveal what's happening with the
time keepers as they portal in looking for
lady Loki you see her watching them on the
monitors they split the teams up sort of setting
up this big twists she sets the countdown
clock for the bombs and we find her enchanting
this man here causing it to take advantage
these ultra low hurricane discounts on his
alien flowers.
Like got a get in on this discount prices.
She uses her magic in and swap the enchantment,
so she's not entering B15's body or possessing
her.
Like this, she just transferred the enchantment
and knocking this person out so quickly that
it seems like there was some body swapping
going on.
But lady Loki is casting this magic from nearby
in a different part of the store.
Like she's using these different people as
finger puppets basically because our Loki
doesn't immediately detect it this her to
play it more for that joke about who's the
real Loki is in who's the copy.
Please, if anyone is anyone, you're another
version of me just all the superior Loki jokes
it as part of this whole arc of the TVA being
the real villains here over and Mobeus is
group yes to stop one of his other TVA hunters
from harassing the people like a they're all
scared here because the disaster.
We don't also want to make them scared of
us to they also find Hunter see 20 who still
kind of out of her mind repeating the phrase
it's real.
They haven't completely answered what that
is that she's referring to.
But she also reveals that she told lady Loki
the secret of how to find and locate the time
keepers I think the twist with that is the
time keepers themselves will be in a separate
pocket dimension.
Like at the end of actual time Loki asked
for the files on the end of time they will
given to them.
But the idea.
There in a separate pocket dimension separated
from the rest of the time keepers citadel
in the TVA.
Like in a separate space that you can't just
walk to this whole last act of the episode
is kind of like a Loki versus lady Loki within
trading barbs back and forth like he tries
to make fun of her for using enchantment magic
is kind of amateurish this also kind of an
Easter egg for the enchantress in marvel comics
and was was wondering when she is going to
show up.
They did her sister Lorelai on the agents
of shield TV show but they never actually
done legit enchantress in the movies are on
the TV shows before lady Loki also tries to
call him out for working for the TVA being
one of their stooges then he tries to explain
that he's really trying to play them along
con even though she doesn't believe him.
Like yeah right, whatever.
Then in rapid succession she jump through
a bunch of different bodies in the male to
female transitions here are just meant to
be another reference to Loki in the comics
and in real world Norse mythology changing
genders all the time Loki tries to offer her
a team up bargain that he's going to overthrow
the time keepers even though she is one of
anything to do with it.
She continues to stall for time like they're
both back and forth just speechifying stalling
for more time he makes the funny joke about
finally understanding how Thor feels why he
so pissed off with him all the time now interest
in a Thor feels he won't shut up when Lady
Loki explains that she's not interested in
otherthrowing the time keepers I think this
because she wants to destroy the entire TVA
itself and the sacred timeline.
Like completely get rid of everything.
As evidenced when she uses the time bombs
at the end of the episode to blow that sacred
timeline into a thousand different branches
of a funny Thor's hammer reference when Loki
calls the Roomba to himself and beats her
with it.
Let he who is worthy wield the powers of Roomba
that she finally reveals her true form stepping
out unfurling her hood and you see her horns.
Her characters actually in Imola gum of lady
Loki in the iKol character from the comics
to completely different characters.
Which is playing the idea the both of those
characters gender swapped quite a bit lady
Loki came from this big siege event that Marvel
had it was sort of the original version of
Loki taking over sifts body or a body that
was meant for sieve until eventually he took
his male Loki form again then died again and
was sort of reborn into the iKol version of
Loki in all those different identity changes
where he was taking different forms male and
female happened after or during big apocalyptic
events like your seeing during the episode
here, so just big callback to their origin
stories during the episode than when she says
this isn't about you just as the bombs are
all going off obviously it's a reference to
her, not really caring what happens to him.
Like she's here to try and take out the complete
time variance authority of the time keepers
themselves the sacred timeline.
She doesn't care what happens the alternate
variant Loki's but is also a metaphor about
positioning herself as the superior version
of Loki in in a funny meta way saying no the
show isn't about you is really about me because
her ego is just as big as our version of Loki's
ego.
But as all the bombs are going off they start
registering the fracturing sacred timeline
and the time bears authority.
You could ravonna Renslayer's monitor in the
actually show you were a lot of these events
are happening and allow them are big Easter
eggs and the marvel movies, there's Vietnam
in 1522 Portugal in 1492, there's vormir in
the year 2301 that's another soul stone reference
or red skull reference black widow died on
vormir in 2014.
So I don't think it's meant to be a black
widow reference Thorton USA in 1550 one Cookeville
in 1999 Asgard in 2004.
That would've actually been just before the
events of the first Thor movie Rome in 1390
Sakaar in 1984, 1984 was the year incredible
hulk number 300 was released.
It was is huge giant sized issue with black
costume Spider-Man teaming up with Dr. strange
trying to stop hulk from destroying New York
city after he become the savage hulk there's
borrowed Charro Columbia in 1808 Corfu Finland
in 1708 there's one on ego the living planet
in the year 1382, there's one on thanos's
homeworld of Titan in 1982.
Thanos did have a small backup role in the
1982 storyline the death of captain marvel,
there's one in New York City in 1947 that's
actually the year a massive smallpox outbreak
happen not too dissimilar from what happened
to us in 2020 with the virus there's Tokyo
in 1984 there was a big earthquake that happened
in Japan that year, there's a whole lot in
the year 51 which is the Kree homeworld near
the turn of the millennia Kingsport 1999 Xandar
in one thousand and one.
That's the homeworld of the nova corps 2005
in Beijing Madrid in 1903 and the list keeps
going on and on and on but they cut to ravonna
Renslayer's face of the reaction just completely
horrified by everything.
Grabbing her stun baton running out, you also
see on her helmet that when she was a hunter
her designation was a 23 then as you rush
into the hallway you see all those portals
opening this is the point of departure like
the train station the depot so to speak were
all the hunters go on their missions from
the going to all the different places try
and close him down like, there's one in Portland
that they rush to there's one on ego the living
planet.
They rush to one of the reasons why think
that lady Loki is doing this is not only to
create all these branch timelines, but also
the idea that you have all these hunters every
single person that they have trying to go
to all these different realities to close
down the branch timelines, leaving the TVA
unprotected so that she can then break-in
and get to the time keepers she picks of the
time pad device from one of the bombs then
opens a portal escaping, Loki chasing after
her.
Just as Mobeus comes running along the stop
him and then the action make some changes
to the end credits scenes you pry notice there's
a clearly visible file on lady Loki amongst
all the other files on our version of Loki,
including the DB cooper event you see Sophia
Dimartino's name appear in the credits right
after this she's the actress who's playing
lady Loki is also different see music on the
credits to which sounds totally badass.
They did the same thing during falcon and
winter soldier with a change the end credits
just a little bit as new characters were revealed
they also do another close up on Loki's file
at the variant of the credits reminding you
about his gender designation as fluid, because
of all the different versions of Loki that
we saw during the episode in the idea that
female Loki was body swapping male to female
a couple different times also this device
here the you see in the credits is not a sling
ring from the doctor strange movie is as she
one of their little devices they used to rewind
time for individuals that he saw during episode
one, but everybody let me know in the comments
what your favorite moment from the episode
was.
I will do it episode three trailer video next.
But if you spot any big Easter eggs in the
episode that I didn't talk about during the
video just right them blown the comments I've
a couple other big Loki, Easter egg in bonus
videos plan for this week too.
So if you have any special requests just leave
them in the comments below in only my giveaway
winner in my Loki trailer video that I post
next but everyone click here for all my Loki
episode videos and click here to learn why
the infinity stones don't work on Loki anymore.
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys tonight!